hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the game of bad decisions
I'm gonna try to not die horribly
because apparently you can live a long
time but I'm just an idiot so my king
it seems your army has very poor hygiene
we should spend a bit on this problem
yeah that seemed good those good trade
if we found some gold in the mines
should we try to dig deeper well if I
know anything from Lord of the Rings it
always said that digging to TV yes of
course you should dig deeper you son of
a [ __ ] the tower of the Basilica is
falling apart we need your help I don't
know what a basilica is so no that could
be heathen talk the merchants would like
to create a new guild and send their
representative to the court yeah ah why
does that Oh Rex moans in despair
something is not right kick the dog no
hit the dog
okay so the score is now 666 this will
have an effect every year diabolic time
is gone space is insane here it comes
here again you feel your mouth closing
down if you never had one oh why did
that happen I just wanted a better
Poochie
little King little puppet I have no
choice here
Oh God no words few thoughts
oh it's guy brush oh oh
many death is everybody oh geez
centuries ago you asked for eternal
power in exchange for your soul
fortunately you didn't mention anything
about immortality eating each of your
deaths is very enjoyable but even more
so is the choice I will let you make now
go a little puppet and see you again in
six hundred sixty-six years
okay I had no idea that would be a part
of this game wow that's actually
legitimately cool but horrifying like
whoa oh boy wait oh I don't like that
that's not a good thing why why do I
have that I don't want the characters to
die I won't operate is not a score as I
imagined it's the year okay the doctor
is conducting ungodly experiments in a
hidden room he must be stopped
I'm well aware of that fact hopefully he
can get the devil off my back because
[ __ ] dude okay this is the coldest
winner of the last thirty years after
the weak harvest your people are
starving but if I say yes to the doctor
he's gonna die I don't want him to die I
can't help can't help the merchants
guild is selling goods traditionally
produced by the abbey but an end of this
a body was found later that year
horrifyingly torn and bloated I'm sorry
about that whatever your name was
because I didn't even do you the common
courtesy of looking we heard about a
young princess being held against her
will in dark Rock my horse
oh [ __ ] if it's a trap my horse you ride
the dark rock and full armor proud
glorious and glittering uh-oh breathing
fire are you the king or are you here
for the damsel oh I should have saved it
for this one
oh I shoulda seen the killin ater to
this one oh good there taker ah I could
have killed the dragon
but nobody's killing anyone you're here
for the girl here she is end a story
okay my hero
Lady Grey I've already met you Lady Grey
my hero yes no yes no yes all right okay
are you packed sorry
did you enjoy our little entertainment
the dragon was not cheap oh okay oh boy
a group of villagers pretend they're
assaulted by celestial beings it's
probably a trick to pay less tax now
yeah call [ __ ] on that one your
people are starving my lord the price of
bread is too high I found blue and brown
mushrooms in the forest the blue one
seems edible oh I've got a ton achieve
oh man called try the blue one I'm gonna
try the blue one
oh [ __ ] blue mushroom you feel suddenly
very happy then strange things start to
happen
oh hi puck how you doing saya we should
spend some money to build a communal
bond of Verve and famine ah the bar was
expensive but it's good protection to
avoid famine and the people's unrest it
was the devil's fault
I blame devil I could have killed that
dragon but I [ __ ] up just generally I
want to state that for the record and
everybody out there you guys already
know but I [ __ ] up bad like bad okay
anyway bar doing but doing I'm gonna
meet the witch recruit the spy and half
an heir Who am I now well I'm gonna have
an error
I would like to conduct new research on
weapons in warfare
will you help you no I will you know I
will
I would like to conduct a mass to the
memory of your father that guy was
freaking possessed by the devil even
though my name is literally bad doing
I'd like to think it's baud but I'm
pretty sure it's pronounced bad doing as
in I'm doing bad but no that guy was a
dick
the Astari of the river drop is a
dangerous swarm for travelers we should
sanitize the whole area nah the queen of
the south is offering you 40 books we
should build a library okay I met a
strange lady well-versed in the ancient
arts of plants and dreams would you like
to meet her oh yeah oh god damn it meet
the witch oh god damn it is the devil
gonna lead me to the witch
okay all right all right here we go be
nice
wafting wafting from now on you will
know more precisely how you yeah how
your decisions affect the kingdom is it
a gift or a malediction ooh oh that's
lovely
I'm lady kharkova I can help you
understand the laws of nature and limits
of humankind be discreet about this lady
kharkova
the church is weak and the people
blasphemous no yes give us enough power
to enforce the divine justice in your
country the Pope is ready to pay the
price
I completely agree or maybe I don't
maybe I do though heck yeah I can teach
you a few things about magic oh hell yes
yes please
but first you have to prove worthy of my
time Oh am I about to knock out two
achievements by knocking boots [ __ ] dad
first you have to prove worthy of your
time yes it's pronounced the holy words
of Gondo in the Eastern fashion wham
slam whoa is it slam whoa are we gonna
blow if you know what I mean ha i'ma go
slam whoa that was nothing I can't
believe slam whoa wasn't the right
answer all right fine then we want to
build a new marketplace it will open our
economy the foreign trade sure okay help
the communal barn is on fire send the
garrison yeah okay we need to build it
God with you and your church [ __ ] you I
would like to open a couple of shops for
my wares and charms
that's okay maybe not be too
open about the fact that there's a witch
in the kingdom I would like to sing a
song for your majesty it's called the
fool in its majesty yeah sure if this
guy wants to sing why not sing away
buddy it was a long time ago and a
pauper was singing alone sad very sad
song he had a majestic pet as a
companion a very dark and ugly beast
carry on but nice and clean and with a
constantly wagging tail thank you oh ok
I guess that's the end of the song then
why didn't I want my guards to arrest
him in the middle of the song do you
need some credit my lord
I like credit I like credit I'll take
that should we build embassies in
neighboring countries it may be good at
preventing war sure ok would you like to
play red door no I learned my lesson
[ __ ] you it's time to pay your debt
milord
[Music]
no the Goldsmith of the capital created
a cartel they organized their trade they
want your approval yes ok that's not so
bad I got lots of money
the king of the West has been informed
of our state of our army and is now
attacking us retreat and regroup
tweet-tweet who the Frick is peel who's
in charge of this bird Holly did you let
it burn in here god damn it
your birds are getting everywhere um
thank you hey thanks hey thanks thanks
you're under arrest you have broken the
commandments of the blessed church sorry
oopsy poopsy Oh theocracy you won't be
able to say no to the church anymore
that said they're taking care of the
money
oh ok alrighty then the message says a
village in the south is encouraging
polygamy
yeah said the church Church left a love
that oh wait did the church just go down
there and join the polygamists I don't
know let me build fortifications around
the Capitol it's costly but well worth
the bother yeah the church's taking care
of it
hell yeah high walls the extra
fortifications are excellent way to
repel invaders useful when your army is
weak our economy is flourishing thanks
to our effort to regulate trade we
should create a central bank I don't
need it we're under a theocracy we need
better defenses the barbarians from the
eastern bear knees are on the border of
our kingdom berm okay all right cool
yeah fine cos I'm a pain for jack-shit
over here our enemies want peace treaty
this is the best way to end war how
about [ __ ] them
alright fine we can do a peace treaty I
suppose Oh everyone's happy yay I could
build a hospital to prevent a surge of
havoc epidemics what about the doctor we
have a doctor saya your urines my little
hooded rhododendrons this morning you
should avoid riding for a while I should
have built that hospital because this
guy's been sniffing my piss okay do I
really have to tell you why the doctor
can't run a hospital yes wait no I don't
get it
I want I want the hospital I I want the
hospital okay no I'm gonna assume this
is literal and no you don't have to tell
me I want it I didn't intend sue so how
about the hospital okay I can't say no
to the church so it's good to have a
little hurt with them the hospital will
limit the consequence of epidemics and
catastrophes that which is awesome thank
you which there's been a massive break
out from the prison we need to organize
a search party
no we're okay there's been an explosion
at the capital we don't exactly know
what happened shall we close the gates
yeah okay
the merchants guild would like to adorn
the marketplace of the capital with a
statue of your majesty
oh [ __ ] really don't take some of that
statue you say it's been another
explosion we need to be able to use the
churches to help victims ah that's not
good the people of the Western village
are afraid of goblins who should take
care of this the Vikings are taken good
God what can't everything just calm its
collective tits for like two years
good god Vikings are attacking us we
should defend our kingdom from the north
okay defend I would like to meet up with
some of my scientists friends from the
West in your castle no wait a minute
here I'm a good teacher let's bet a bit
of money okay on guard what did you
learn that move the hospital yes with a
pretty nurse yes whoo ha ha you feel the
general Arnold okay Wow Oh you miss me
angry boy your breath is a better weapon
than that toothpick of yours good god
[Music]
yes ha ha gotcha all right silly taunt
ha ha okay I'm good thanks all right
what side of the road should carriages
go on oh no oh no I'm from America and
we say the right long live the king
you're turning 50 years old today so I
went into power when I was 12
yes don't tell me yes yes yes yes yes
milord a mast arrived the merchants
guild master please accept a token of
our gratitude
I take no bribe I'm noble like that I
would like to conduct new research on
the fabled transmutation of lead into
gold
could you finance me okay Islanders are
menacing us we should attack them before
they attack us
no these thin bear knees are at war
again and their population is crossing
our frontier as we speak okay while
doing my research had designed a rather
clever way to distill alcohol I would
like to share the revenue may we need
money the church apparently has rules
and Kaboodle's of money the population
is scared by terrorists please suspend
the payment of taxes here okay all right
I heard strange noises in the castle
last night we should have more guards
patrolling lady car cobia you're in the
castle yes enforce the state of
emergency that's the only way to deal
efficiently with these turds yeah oh
that's a lot of that's a lot of that's a
lot of military do you trust me my lord
no new new new
I only trust me and my own our flag
should really be changed it's not really
fashionable what are the options brown
spade on gray sky
oh yeah no Red Cross on a golden field
oh god I can only say yes fall all right
fine
the King of the West is visiting us oh
all right fine we should organize a
grand dinner good idea
terrible idea the king will prefer to go
hunting dinner I remember a certain king
somewhere somehow that died when he was
hunting so no the king of the West is
preparing an attack on one of our
province
well sack of tits I just welcomed him
into my house there's a bunch of
[ __ ] huh
fine builder damn he found gold in the
river bed do you want what do you want
to do with the income with everybody the
covenant of nuns has started meowing
like cats again why do I care and
they're dead my research is not working
should I carry on yes forever whoa what
happened with my money my money
what is the theocracy got I like the
theocracy the theocracy was great why
did that run out we cross the invading
armies in the looting is excellent okay
Bravo ah that's not good that's not good
that's not good Oh you wake up in the
middle of the night feeling the years
bending your back you are old and tired
stay awake old age you won't be able to
hear or understand properly scared you
try to hug drew try very hard a bailment
from the court oh okay
this is a coup sir in your power to move
this is a coup surrender your Powe war
to moe at onk oh Jesus oh geez well I
was old anyway ah shitty tits I didn't
know that was gonna raise the power of
the army that much the army locks you up
in the tallest tower that castle where
you're Decatur rags and bones well [ __ ]
I did good though but do you have bad
doing the ancient I'd say that's pretty
darn good
Oh holy [ __ ] I made it a long way
I like it a lot oh that's cool this game
is cool this game is like really cool so
anyway that's all the time I have for
this episode I don't know if I'm gonna
be making more episodes let me know if
you do this is a lot of fun and there
seems to be like a lot of variety out of
it I mean some things repeat obviously
but it seems like there's a cohesive
story stitching everything together so
it'd be kind of cool to see where it
leads but I'll leave that up to you so
thanks again and as always I'll see you
in the next video bye bye
you